>> Pete: WELCOME BACK.
WHILE THE SOUTHERN BORDER AS WE
KNOW IS OVERRUN BY MIGRANTS,
IT'S NOT THE ONLY PLACE IN
AMERICA SEEING INFLUX OF
REFUGEES.
THE WELCOME MAT IS OFFICIALLY
NOW BEING LAID OUT FOR MIGRANTS
COMING FROM AFGHANISTAN.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, TODAY A
FLIGHT CARRYING 75 UNACCOMPANIED
AFGHAN CHILDREN LANDED IN THE
GLAMOROUS CITY OF CHICAGO.
THIS NUMBER IS IN ADDITION TO
THE 860 AFGHAN REFUGEES THAT THE
STATE OF ILLINOIS IS ALREADY
PLANNING ON WELCOMING IN THE
COMING WEEKS.
WITH 550 OF THOSE BEING
CHILDREN.
AND TO BE CLEAR, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THIS GROUP DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE BRAVE INTERPRETERS
WHO WENT THROUGH THE SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT VISA PROCESS AND WERE
VETTED AFTER FIGHTING ALONGSIDE
AMERICAN TROOPS AGAINST THE
TALIBAN.
THESE ARE AT RISK KIDS, MANY
WITHOUT PARENTS OR SPONSORS,
WAITING FOR THEM IN THE WINDY
CITY.
MEANING THEY WILL BE WARDS OF
THE GOVERNMENT, WHICH CAN'T EVEN
ATTACK CARE OF THE KIDS ALREADY
LIVING IN CHICAGO, A CITY THAT
HAS ALREADY SEEN AT LEAST 261
KIDS SHOT ALONE THIS YEAR.
NOT TO MENTION A CITY WHERE 80%
OF 8TH GRADERS DON'T READ AT
GRADE LEVEL.
TAKING IN KIDS FROM A COUNTRY
WITH A 38% LITERACY RATE AND
TRUST ME THAT NUMBER IS
GENEROUS.
SO, CHICAGO CAN'T EVEN TAKE CARE
OF ITS OWN KIDS AND WE HAVE
EXPECT CHICAGO TO TAKE CARE OF
PARENTLESS AFGHAN CHILDREN.
WHAT IN THE WORLD COULD GO
WRONG?
JOINING ME NOW IS VICTOR DAVIS
HANSON THE AUTHOR OF THE
UPCOMING BOOK "THE DYING
CITIZEN."
AND I DO VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD
TO READING IT EVERYTHING YOU
SAY, VICTOR, IS THOUGHTFUL.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, WE
WELCOME AFGHANS WHO FOUGHT
ALONGSIDE US.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY THAT CAME -- ARE COMING
ARE HEADED TO OUR COUNTRY
WEREN'T IN THAT CATEGORY PER SE
WERE AT RISK.
NOW YOU GOT KIDS GOING TO
CHICAGO.
DO WE HAVE A SYSTEM SET UP TO
ABSORB THEM PROPERLY?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK CHILDREN IN CHICAGO WHO
ARE U.S. CITIZENS WILL FAIR
WORST THAN EVEN REFUGEES.
WE ARE KIND LIKE OF 19TH SEN DRY
BRITISH EMPIRE THAT HAD A PORT
OR BASE ALL OVER THE WORLD BUT
CHARLES DICKENS WRITING AT HOME
ABOUT POVERTY AND CRIME AT THE
HEART OF IT ALL IN LONDON.
WE HAVE HOLLOWED OUT OUR CITIES
AND YET WE THINK WE CAN SPREAD
ALL OF OUR CULL TRURE FLY PRIDE
FLAGS AND HAVE GEORGE FLOYD MUIR
HIEWRLS.
HOLLOWED OUT AT HOME.
THE SOLDIERS ASKED TO ACCOMPANY
THE REFUGEES EVEN IF THEY HAVE
HAD ANTIBODIES AND PRIOR CASE OF
COVID THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
GET VACCINATED.
PEOPLE COMING FROM AFGHANISTAN
OR THE 2 MILLION AT THE BORDER,
EVEN IF THEY HAVEN'T HAD COVID,
THEY WON'T ASK TO BE VACCINATED.
AND YOU AND I, PETE, WE CAN'T
PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH LAWS WE
FOLLOW.
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
THE FIRST THING THEY DO IS BREAK
THE LAW.
THE SECOND THING THEY DO IS
BREAK THE LAW BY RESIDING HERE.
PROBABLY THE THIRD WILL BE SOME
TYPE OF I.D.
CAN'T SAY I'M NOT GOING TO
FOLLOW AN IRS LAW.
I DON'T LIKE THIS FEDERAL GUN
REGISTRATION LAW SO I'M GOING TO
AVOID IT AND DUONG MENTIONED THE
DAN BONGINOMENTIONED WHEN I COME
UNITED STATES I'M PARANOID ABOUT
HAVING MY PASSPORT.
I'M A CITIZEN.
NON-CITIZENS DON'T WORRY ABOUT
THAT APPARENTLY.
PART OF A LARGER PROJECT.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATIC AND LEFT
WING AGENDA MOVEMENT PROJECT
WHATEVER WE CALL IT ON UNHAPPY
WITH THE PRESENT ELECTORATE.
WE HAVE ABOUT 50 MILLION PEOPLE
THAT WERE NOT BORN IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT ARE NOW RESIDING
HERE LEGALLY AND WE THINK IT'S
WE HAVE GOT CHANGE THE
DEMOGRAPHY BECAUSE WE DON'T GET
51% SUPPORT FOR OUR AGENDA AND
THAT'S SORT OF THE ORGAN NIC
ARGUMENT THAT FLIPPED
CALIFORNIA, NEVADA, COLORADO,
MAYBE ARIZONA, NEW MEXICO, MAYBE
SOME DAY GEORGIA.
AND THEN THE ELITES SAY WELL WE
HAVE GOT TO CHANGE THE
ELECTORATE BUT WE HAVE ALSO GET
RID OF THE 9 PERSON SUPREME
COURT, THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE,
THE FILIBUSTER, GET A NATIONAL
VOTING LAW AND GET TWO MORE
STATES BUT IT'S PART OF A LARGER
EFFORT THAT SAYS UNDER THE
EXISTING SYSTEM AND RULES AND
UNDER THE EXISTING ELECTORATE
AND DEMOGRAPHY WE CAN'T GET WHAT
WE WANT SO WE WILL CHANGE BOTH
AT THE OPPOSITE ENDS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
>> Pete: VICTOR REAL QUICK WE
ONLY HAVE ABOUT 45 SECOND.
DO THEY BELIEVE THESE KIDS WILL
SUCCEED WHEN THEY GET HERE OR DO
THEY KNOW THE SYSTEM WILL FAIL
THEM AND AS YOU POINTED OUT THEY
ARE NOT JUST THAT CONCERNED
ABOUT IT?
>> NO, I THINK THEY THINK -- I
WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF SOCIAL
WORKERS FOCUS ON THEM IN A
GREATER FASHION THAN THEY DO THE
UNDER CLASS OF CHICAGO.
WE HAVE -- I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
IS.
IT'S SOME KIND OF WEIRD TELL YOU
CAN YOU RECALL TICK THAT IF YOU
ARE NOT A CITIZEN AND COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY, EVEN WITHOUT
LEGALITY OR MAYBE NOT THROUGH
THE LEGAL LENGTHY PROCESS, WE
ARE GOING TO DO ALL WE CAN FOR
NEW A WAY THAT WE HAVE ABANDONED
OUR OWN.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ELSE TO EXPLAIN
IT.
IF YOU ARE A YOUNG
AFRICAN-AMERICAN CHILD, GROWING
UP IN CHICAGO, I THINK WE ARE
GOING TO GIVE YOU YOUR PARENTS
SOME MONEY OR SUBSUBSIDY DID I
WE ARE OUT OF SIGHT, OUT OF
MIND.
WE DON'T CARE ABOUT YOU.
THAT'S A TERRIBLE THING TO SAY
BUT THAT'S OUR ATTITUDE.
WE PREFER PEOPLE FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY THAN WE DO OUR OWN
CITIZENS, THAT'S A COMMENTARY
WHERE WE ARE.
>> Pete: IT'S THE EXACT OPPOSITE
OF AMERICA FIRST.
PRECISELY WHAT IT IS WHEN YOU
DON'T BELIEVE YOURSELF YOU LOOK
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
>> IT IS CITIZENSHIP LAST.